we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P take a listen to this hey
David this is Mike from Sacramento I
just want to say like when I like your
show a lot too
um the last four family gatherings that
I've had uh like my right wing relatives
all they talk about all they talk about
is like transgender sex like how much
they hate to you know
the different you know whatever there's
like one one uh transgender woman that
beats people in like swimming and that's
all they talk about that's the most
important thing in the entire world yep
um that in life black mermaids and black
people shouldn't be in any movies
basically so I think listen folks Santa
Claus is white and mermaids are white
why can't these wokesters understand
that like this next election we need to
be prepared for any response that can we
can do regarding those types of things
yeah I think like Chris Christie even
though I agree he does sound pretty
smart to me and to you
um they the Republicans don't care about
that stuff anymore they don't care about
taxes or foreign policy all they care
about is culture wars so I think we have
to have good responses for that stuff my
response to them was it's like they're
saying oh we're concerned that um
transgender people are just going into
women's dress dressing rooms to rape
them well guess what Donald Trump went
into a dressing room dressed as a man
and he raped somebody so they can't you
know using that as sexually assaulted
hold on a second hold on a second let's
be clear uh no the caller is I mean
that's crazy that and it is incredible
that these are the conversations you
know at one point the sort of
Thanksgiving conversations were very
politically uh stressful but they were
about like tax policy and foreign policy
now it's about black mermaids and that
is that is a really crazy commentary
about where we are today folks we've got
a Bonus show coming up right after this
show make sure you're subscribed at
joinpakman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show we've got an incredible
week of shows coming up I will be at a
wedding on the west coast we've got a
great cast of fill-ins and then I'm
gonna be back with you so strongly so
strongly folks on Monday please be nice
to the guest hosts uh at least to their
face okay you can email me later and
complain but please be nice to their
face we'll see you on the bonus show and
then everything just continues
throughout the rest of the week